[Music]
right now until they're scientists and
little bit which recently acquired like
I'm a straight line a lot of so skip
like a smart nose bases build itself
using deep learning from your voice
communications and what that means is
that it reflects on product analysis
which is that the state of your business
is reflected multiple different channels
in completely so you're gonna be ours
your your tickets your confluence
documents your slack messages each of
these provides a picture of this high
dimensional structure that's difficult
for you to see in its complete totality
which together paint tableau of the
actual structure of your business that
is different from the ordinary or the
matrix management that you participated
the people that you actually get work
done with are different from the people
that are necessarily longer team and so
we believe that we can understand this
structure and help you connect with
information that will make you more
effective in the workplace so that looks
like performing semantic joints across
these different information channels to
aggregate information about individual
topics and connect that to a knowledge
graph that understands the structure of
the real world
so how about the headquarters Facebook
Mark Zuckerberg CEO and also in their
skins of topics internal to your team so
if you have special project names things
like this we understand the
relationships between those entities and
can use that structure to perform
natural language question answering and
expedited so I can say how do I mount an
e BS volume on the remote dev server and
if somebody has answered that
coincidentally in slack without
anticipating that I'm going to be asking
a question later on we can just
automatically sir
additionally if we don't have an answer
and we can back off to the set of people
who are likely to help you resolve your
issue and so this is what it looks like
we have joint work they be able to
integrate the power of the work day
draft which is the system platform
record for thousands of enterprises some
of the hundreds of thousands of
employees that's that's a beautiful
highly structured data set and we are
marrying this unstructured knowledge
understanding platform with the
structure that's present mandated
healthy workplace and so what this talk
is about is it reflects sort of
battle-hardened lessons from building
natural language understanding and
natural language processing pipelines in
production environments under deadlines
within a high degree of certainty and so
this is really consensus the talk that I
would love to occurred a year and a half
or two years ago just in terms of like
these are important things to know about
building natural language processing
technologies and here's how to cut to
the chase because you have to do
equipment so one of the actually if I
can this applause so that I can help
calibrate where I invest time how many
people here have worked with embedding
vectors like word debecker glove even at
a prototyping capacity okay that's great
so one of them would be to our data
engineers so one of the key insights
that that really came out of this
experience it's go flag was that you
have to stand your models up in
production as quickly as possible and
get those workflows running on a
scheduled basis and exercise those
pipelines is based possible so you start
seems and begin to understand the
failure states and so we've often worked
on a four-week cadence where we invest
two weeks and reading the literature of
standing up models I have no books were
just kicking the tires on various
student code from Stanford I know you
mad and just seeing what we could do to
solve a problem here and then we would
send the second two weeks standing that
up in production so even if the model
was incomplete Lord did not have a high
degree of accuracy the idea that we
should wired into a production status
totally as possible was central to how
we were able to solve this puzzle and
iterate and harden needs on an ongoing
basis rate and have metrics that you're
tracking for you tomorrow that it's just
like a competition at that point so one
of the techniques that we would use
during the ideation research base was -
I love this disappointment so true
really you want to have this incredibly
strong and that's the place to start so
there this is part of this talk is going
to be talking about off-the-shelf
technologies that I've used to say okay
if I can't be fast fast it's I'm not
really sure whatever we're building in
technology and so having this ability to
detach yourself from an investment and
not built here as a way to establish a
foundation is actually a super powerful
so simple is great especially when
you're getting started so as regards the
the infrastructure that we used to
deploy these models and then be able to
dis pretty quickly I think a lot of
people have expressed an interest in
this slide because it's not it's still
kind of an open problem how to employee
and a levels in production environments
in a way that treats infrastructure
linka and we are set a little roughly
like this where we have a developer
laptop here on the bottom that we use
our sink to deploy code
code to ec2 instances which have all of
our model a within within under
containers that were pulled from plastic
container registry all her modeling
pipelines various tools that we could
update the container image and iterate
to build these artifacts in the form of
either surrealist central objects or
psychic pipelines that would exist in
conjunction with this metadata database
Mahatma as a on disk on this persistence
layer for feature sets that don't
necessarily all belong in memory a
little bit so those two assets together
in conjunction once sufficient would get
deployed to the best three and we would
updates all configuration files on the
local repo and then pushed us to a
feature branch for circle see I have
been getting poked and run a battery of
tests to make sure that we were on track
with the latest decoder and those are
those tests are running in these
containers that are also painful for me
CR once that gets merged in I mastered
the elastic container registry gets
updated and code employed will push
containers and code to a sweep of
production knowledge extraction machines
that are then ensured to be running the
same version of the metadata database
that's original model positive source
code across all of our instances and so
this was a really nice way to package up
and maintain consistent state across all
of our development development
environment in our production systems so
that metadata database that I was
talking about was baked on top of rocks
TV it could have been something else but
props DB worked for us I think the
pattern though is instructive in the
sense that often it's particularly the
text because the frequency with which
you observe a given word follows as it
distribution which is a long tail
distribution so many many words our
access to highly frequently is and it's
and a lot of words are accessed highly
infrequently and so the idea is storing
all that back in memory doesn't make a
lot of sense it's a lot of ways few
because there are keys that you're going
to hit only every 15,000 words and so
instead and you can use this tiered
caching architecture where I write and
so here what I have is a key which would
be a token or a URL and then I have a
value which would be for example a word
of that combating vector or the PageRank
of one of ten billion different websites
right so I have high dimensionality or
high cardinality features that I wanted
is going in to help my big data but they
don't necessarily all belong in milk so
I may be materializing only a subset of
those and so by writing the gerak Stevie
I can pull them up off disk in a way
that doesn't invoke the network overhead
of calling out like back home for
example and I can perform my modeling
predictive modeling in memory
constrained environment so this gonna
fall additional rocks to use sports
basketball writing because this is
something that we're materializing less
frequently than we're painting the model
it makes a lot of sense to write quickly
more slowly
we wrapped that with an LRU cache and
put in front of it this is satisfying to
see that were a prefix try that helps us
avoid hits to the database in the event
that the key is not present so we saw
the baffle about 30 I just saying you
know bring back off because he didn't
exist individuals so that's a little bit
better infrastructure how we stood this
stuff I know that I can't I'm so sorry
so that's basically the high-level view
learning for start
and I want to talk a little bit more
about natural language processing mm-hmm
and the structure of these different
data sets that that are pretty good
examples of how people actually speak so
the when you were working with natural
language you have that natural language
that reflects your target domain so the
way the newswire articles is regarded
and is pretty different from how people
can pose language on twitter is
different from how people who are in
finance talk about training you need to
have a domain of training data that is
similar or a proxy for the thing that
you're actually covered and so there are
various open data sets that have huge
volumes of natural language that inform
the structure of the semantic structure
of the models and they're different some
importantly is so common probably is
great petabyte scale it's available for
free on AWS it is noisy very unicode
errors there are lots of foreign
language text it is messy data set and
it's also not always clear how to parse
HTML to extract the content that are
interested it but it's you and that's
really powerful
Wikipedia mm-hmm mrs. mrs. blog this is
their pista does the Ernest speak for
just what it is Wikipedia on the other
hand is written like encyclopedia
articles and that's not how anybody
talks
what's more Wikipedia has a very
specific kind of structure in terms of
how its header materials produce this is
really not likely because it's linked
and you understand the relationships
between concepts at a meta level in
addition to the coincidence of terms
that income semantic information but
it's not really how people actually and
so that your models will have a gap in
terms of their ability to generalize to
domains that are messy or not written
like news articles twitter is very much
at the other end of the spectrum it's be
short on grammatical poorly punctuated
for the capitalized utterances
screaming into the void but that's
really great if you're trying to train a
model of PAS welding under under
adversarial conditions so you can pull
out a lot of really hard test examples
from Twitter and if your model performs
well on Twitter it is likely that it
will perform well on other kinds of
domains whereas if your model for me
you're coming from well that's her
office regards whether or the
generalizable in short times so if you
fit embedding records and I'll get into
a PC room what that means on each of
these different purpose systems this is
really that kind of like I want to
understand the relationships between
words and I can say which words are most
similar to occupy in a weird event model
actually love model fit on each of these
different purposes and you see that the
structure of this vector series is the
structure this vector space reflects the
semantics of the purpose at the time
when the copies burned so this Twitter
this is these are stanford NLP group
anchored structures group level vectors
that are fit on Twitter and you see that
Twitter is really really makes my
occupies being a political protest token
and it reflects that occupying Lebanon
and occupying Burma were trending topics
at the time when this is a twisted
whereas Wikipedia really does not have
that it thinks a bit much more as a verb
which is related to geo spatial
relationships play twice economy has
more of that protest dimension so if
you're fitting a model which assumes I
ain't Li for example that occupy is
going to be treated as a verb and your
corpus of reference treats it pretty
much as a political you're going to
20 confusing us away involves a party
and so understanding the Santa source
beta is kind of important for getting
things that work in the way that you
expect so once you have the the sort of
work space in which to perform this work
there are a variety of tools that you
might use to have to the chaser and so
this idea of give me something that
works quickly and effectively is that
the are you know something I asked
myself all the time and really did I
think it's interesting to think about
this evolution is technologies in the
historical context or vector space model
enterprise so just to establish that
their common foundation of it I'll share
the basic intuition with vector space
model is that I can count the number of
times a token occurs in the document
where it occurs at will tell me
something about the semantics for
example words of an affair or documents
about orienteering
here these two vectors will have a
certain number of references to word
declination with certain number of
references or asthma and I can measure
we observe because of the slight moments
of those documents they tend to point
the same direction in this vector space
if they're about the same topic and so I
can measure the cosine of that angle
between these two documents to define a
measure of relatedness now this produces
for me if I have all of my documents as
prose and the matrix and all of my
totals as columns in this matrix a very
sparse matrix and up until maybe $20.99
the smartest thing to do was to perform
some supreme dimensionality reduction on
that corpus and save projected from
hundreds and thousands of tokens where
many of the columns in that matrix are
you know we only have one or two nonzero
entries down to the dense matrix of just
100 dimensions where intuitively under
the properties of the co2 value
decomposition correlations between these
different dimensions are collapsed and
now we have these top representations
that correspond to things like
orienteering business and this this has
been this is this basic that gets you to
do
Netflix style and fun style people also
view type recommendations you're not
wrong but you're not like so this yeah
this is the speaker content makers
they're talking about this lets you do
all of the downstream tasks but it's
possibly a tional clustering i'm trying
to rank this this basic unit of analysis
is what we're trying to move towards in
terms of this document feature images
we're now each document is a point
either in this space or this lower
dimensional so the reason that we're due
back became so important is that it in
under these original inception i don't
know necessarily that there's a
relationship between asthma and
declination i don't know that they're
both great words where did that go into
the properties of its loss function will
capture semantic relations as long as i
suspect many of us have heard this idea
that King is Dumanis woman is de queen
or meanest woman as this certainly where
de Becque understands analogical
reasoning that's pretty cool that's an
important feature that space and so just
kind of dive into what is meant by that
so each point in the word in that space
is a single token so I might have 300
dimensions and the word Queen
occupies I didn't point in that space
and word the word King occupies a
different point in that space and so
what we can do is we can take the
difference between these two vectors and
that produces a third vector and what
what we say in terms of these captions
spaces that the factor between man and
woman and between those metrics are
actually this not us sir the same
there's some very very similar
additionally you can capture other
constellations just like they happen so
Italy is the Romans depends to tell you
those points will be in have similar
relationships in that space and that's
what that's one of the reasons that were
divided such a powerful tool is that
it's encoding the semantics of the
source purpose so you'll also get it's
not things like superlative relations as
good as to better is better is the best
what's troubling about this is that it
encodes the semantics of the source
purpose so if there's gender bias like
registered nurse is to doctor as woman
is to man your model is going to reflect
these biases and so it's important to be
aware of how your your the bias season
become trends into your source data will
inform the structure of your model in
ways that are not necessarily obvious
and maybe so with this collection of
word vectors which encode the teching in
the texture of this high dimensional
space the structure of language we can
now produce document matrices so in the
past I had a document vector where each
of the entries in the vector was a
single okay now I not a document matrix
which was a lot more numbers that I can
use to reason about what's being said
and so typically all word the column
vectors in that matrix in the order in
which words appear in the sentence using
their work attack vectors and now I can
understand an information whether it's a
neural network or centrally use a
derived vector which now gives us back
that document feature matrix that I can
use to reason about any problems our
classification in our clustering or any
of these other downstream applications
this is a much more powerful technique
though so one of the things you can do
to kind of start standing up these
technologies if I want to do
an analysis or news article ranking or
topping lining all of these I want to
produce these document vectors quickly
active thing is use off-the-shelf and
many vectors so the two sort of Maine or
Susannah racer glove and word event I
tended for her love this came out of the
the Stanford NLP group and what's nice
and I love is that it is fitted on very
similar in terms of the performance and
the models that are very comfortable but
I think love provides a lot more degrees
of freedom in terms of working with the
you space but we're working to fit your
use case so if it's first fit on a lot
of different purposes whereas word of
that misfit primarily on Google News and
maybe in terms the off-the-shelf denies
the glove also gives you different
dimensionalities so if I don't
necessarily if I don't have to compute
to store three hundred dimensional
factors for every token in my corpus I
can reduce that down to fifty dimensions
using these off-the-shelf club factors
and save myself a lot of memory overhead
likewise
Google of has been fitted on both case
and uncased purposes so if you consider
casing as semantically very meaningful
the word a mighty with an upper case is
different than worth it if we lower case
the corpus what happens is that I I lose
that distinction there's sort of this
meaning collapse where now I have to
reflect the two different senses of IT
and get in a single veteran so it's
pulgin cross purposes this is useful
however in the case of pronounced so my
common birth or International Business
Machines
whether those are title gates or all
lower case those are the same attic and
in general making section it's made is
that well casing is really hard to
control for I prefer to use all of the
information available to me and so I'm
gonna lower case the corpus at the
expense of
and things that have polysemous meetings
but it's nice to the option to choose
what is what is most appropriate for
your for your problem and then again
this is fit across Wikipedia Comic Con
so we can't I'm building a stock
predictor based on to their sentiment I
can use these off-the-shelf Twitter
vectors rather than some guesswork like
oh that's like a PD and my model will
probably perform better out of the box
in the event that those off-the-shelf
items are insufficient you can pretty
easily
build your own so you just feed in a
corpus of text and you say here are my
observations natural language it's slack
it's live journal it's whatever you want
right people have been developed these
social norms that are distinct across
different domains and so I might want to
fit my own vectors a really simple tool
for doing that as is Jensen it has a
suite of really we didn't actually like
using it for a variety of reasons but I
think in terms of being able to stand
something up very very quickly and make
comparisons between vectors and say what
are the closest factors to this token
how how happy am i with the analogical
reasoning capabilities I think that I've
just fitted it's a really useful Swiss
Army knife for manipulating these these
word events you can also fit your own
embeddings using Jensen however I think
there are if you have really large did I
think some of the stuff that's coming
out from Amazon Sage maker looks pretty
good before doing distribute as word
effect kind of in an off-the-shelf
manner on EMS so Jensen Jensen is a
great option if you're just wanting to
tires on these you can load up one of
these embedding vectors in like two
lines of code to say what what's there
so I lay Jensen block if you bit me so
let's say you were this millions and
millions of documents but it's beautiful
model and II now have this huge matrix
it's all of your tokens and all of the
dimensions of your abetting like now did
it work
you can use the tires with infants and
say well how similar it is you know what
are the K in your speakers to automobile
thanks for leading the cars but you can
also use the tension flow embedding
projector which will let you see using
under various transformations or whose
PCA or multi-dimensional scaling mrs. T
C which is the lightness or projector
high dimensional spaces into a
two-dimensional plane and what what's
cool is that you will get because TC
tries to preserve in a lower dimensional
space the relationships between vectors
you'll start to see some of these
analogical relationships to take shape
in the tendrils of your projecting and
so forth like a concrete example is that
one of these little that would certainly
make like nebula or galaxy sort of wispy
tendrils if you mouse over this you'll
see what the word is and you might have
a structure that looks like the word one
and then at number two and then the word
a few and then some and then the number
10 and then 20 and then a hundred and
then ten thousand and a hundred thousand
and then you have something like a
zillion bajillion and so you have this
this more than relationship that is
encoded both in terms of numbers and
words so you start to see okay like I'm
getting structure in this data that is
capturing something about the underlying
dataset so this is this is a good way to
smoke test whether your your punkest
worked
and what's cool about this is that it
lets you and then anything so you can
work with taxed you can work with images
so this has off-the-shelf support for
little thumbnails on betting pictures in
a high dimensional space
additional members for example I than
that see are all alike sharp and see
images together or you know it's that
next to the crustaceans you can do this
with with anything and so then that's a
really powerful for understanding and a
very kind of like naive way this humans
have a really hard time reason
dimensional spaces whether your model is
working so all of this in context you
probably if you're really trying to
stand one of these things up and build a
business on the back of this kind of
technology you're probably going to find
that the off-the-shelf components don't
meet your needs and so one of the
techniques that's pretty powerful is to
take a if I have a small body of text
let's say legal documents which has this
very idiosyncratic very archaic
structure to the language I don't have
enough documents to really model all of
human expression let's see how the
corpus is a couple hundred thousands
briefs what I can do is take this matrix
of embedding actors from Wikipedia or
common crawl and pre initialize my my
matrix or my my embedding matrix with
small valued random vectors for out of
vocabulary words so there will be words
needs legal documents that are not in
Wikipedia and I want to learn inventing
papers and want to learn representations
or those words so that I can reason
about the semantics of this legal space
and what happens if I if I keep the
common column vectors fixed and then
allow allow updates to the words that
are out there it's what happens is that
the points start to slide around inside
a mental space and this the texture of
it is restructured to adapt to the
constraints of this new corpus and so
you take a good deal of what we know
about how people act
ah from internet and modulated just so
to better reflect the semantics of this
this much smaller dataset that you have
under studying so that's a big powerful
technique for making the most of
customer support tickets or sales emails
you have a very small volume of data you
can leverage up by taking what we know
about the kind of metric space but these
much larger corpuses and permuting the
structure using your your small sample
and what's nice is Jennsen provides
functionality out of the box so you can
freeze those vectors so that's a prequel
and it works relatively well so there
are a lot of different ways to build
weird effects these are these are a few
of the techniques I don't know that if I
had a basic classification problem to
solve that I would go to the trouble of
even just bringing up the word to that
vector is intensive and then wiring
together excitement pipeline and fitting
students model on and making predictions
as to one of the many classes that seems
like a lot of work to me I don't know
fast text for Facebook or BSD licensed
it's pretty good at doing a multi-class
classification on text and it's API
looks like a text file where the first
column or the tab is just labels and the
last of the second column is just the
tax and you say fit them all he'll go in
fill up and then you say predict this
new text and we'll say what's the
likelihood of each of the labels it
works really well since it's a strong
and I talked about take the one that
everybody claims to be and then
implement that I think mass text is
great and it lets you know is there is
it juicier do I have any pasta is it
likely that we'll be able to make any
headway on this problem are there
problems in white pre-processing that
are gonna keep me
getting where I need to be with this
with this problem and so what's cool
about fast taxed is that it uses be
somewhere and medical so you look at
that I made that word up but everybody's
like almost chemical we know about the
relationships between light level tokens
in words and those in for what looks
like a start up mate and what looks like
a chemical or what looks like an Eastern
European name
they have different structure the some
word levels of pass next makes good use
of that sub word structure to learn
embeddings for bite grams then it then
aggregates to form word representations
and what's cool about this is that it
will let you do out-of-band prediction
survival word that I've never seen
before
I can take the embeddings of all of its
and mites and infer and doing bending
for that word and so then this works
really well for there's a new tool that
is have been billed as the spiritual
successor to fast text called star space
that I think is really really powerful
and it uses the same API so if you have
tags and one column is just effects file
tags and then text and what it it's
basically a wrapper around this idea of
a contrasted loss function and so what
that means is that so this is the kind
of technology that underlies I'm
imagining I don't know for a fact if you
go to Google Image Search and you say
man in a blue shirt riding a horse
you'll get pictures of a guy in a blue
shirt riding a horse it's it's about
joint emetic and so what happens here is
that I will take two different in our in
our case sentences and I will project
them into a lower dimensional space
again document bathrooms for trying to
get representations of documents that
are 2 or 300 flow values and I will say
okay I'm going to put documents that are
the same whether these are translations
same sentence or these are things from
the same class
I want to structure my high dimensional
space such that factors document vectors
from the same class pen near Y one
another as measured either in terms of
cosine similarity or Euclidean distance
and I will incur a penalty when
documents from different classes are
also nearby one another that's what
happens is that you just start to push
all of the vectors that are from the
same class into the same region and push
away certain link magnets and springs
vectors that are from different classes
and so what happens under this this
contrastive loss of operation is that
you get an implicit learning to rank
functionality so I can say give me the K
nearest neighbors or give me the the
nearest documents are sorted by score
and if I'm doing for example job
matching for a candidate and job
listings I can say which job listings
most appropriate for this person this
metric that you're using for this
passive loss link
oh and ooh goodness match implicitly in
this basement that's a very very
powerful technology and it's fine you
know and out of the late trouble your
own is some but not trivial mm-hmm and
it's really cool that this provides a
nice CLI interface on to this kind of
level so I I like it
so to kind of bring this around to the
end
Spacey's another great tool for
manipulating structure language it
doesn't let first speech mean that any
recognition tagging you see here display
see which is their CSS doer or
annotations you can bully of even figure
on models for our speech annotation so
if you have a
type of class that you want to identify
for example chemical element you want to
identify all the things that are
chemical elements you can figure on
using Spacey that's a beautiful API it's
reasonably fast the b2 is not as fastest
as people want unfortunately the problem
is that all of these technologies rely
in large measure line the punctuation
the capitalization of these sentences so
if I take this same sentiment lowercase
remove all the punctuation these some
tactical parses where I try to basically
draw the sentence diagram for the for
the utterance on fall apart and so those
tools don't generalize well to things
like Twitter where people are not
behaving well so there's some
technologies like hue that are probably
under the keyphrase extraction rate and
say phrases are to fit this vet will
puncture whether it will without
assigning annotations so I don't know
necessarily if something is a person my
starting organization but it will
partition the sentence such that I don't
the University of Leeds is a single
semantic unit it's not really three
different things it's like identity it
would be usable if I could fit an
embedding vector and reason about that
entity in isolation rather than as the
combination of three different words one
of which is of bad that's gonna hurt my
models so I can partition by
pre-processing my documents into tokens
that are can be reasoned about in
isolation this idea that words are this
the most basic unit of thought is not
really palpable we world these are some
powerful technologies for doing that and
then you can fit these offending vectors
on those purposes and those those
upstream pre-processing steps will have
outsized impact on your downstream
work and so another cut to the chase
moment you could fit a neural network to
vacuum factors sounds like a lot of work
you can just take the tf-idf weighted
centroid of all of the factors in the
document actually works really well so
through a lot of the convenient is that
Wikipedia it never works in practice it
never works in theory it only works in
practice I think this is another thing
that fits that bill this shouldn't work
but it does all the reasons it shouldn't
back the matter as it does I think we're
going to find here the fact reality of
sometimes this doesn't all of this be
sweet note hacks necessarily but just
sort of like good let's let's just get
this done we gotta do this now two weeks
to build this model these are the tools
that I use under the circumstances and
sometimes they're not enough and so that
is when you back off to these more
sophisticated modeling techniques I
think that's probably another but I
think you know it's important to know
that there is a huge number of options
in terms of doing naturally in the first
a natural language processing that are
not contingent so we think about
networks people taxes information
flowing through networks trying to
understand the structure of society
bidding structures that certain strategy
of course of our lives of our success
making that more accessible usable to
individuals for hiring like to think
about that stuff a lot our team has some
of the best people in the business that
seems like something that would be of
interest to you feel free to reach out
Thanks
you